don't walk him to this video playing
carrom ass off I cannot write a region
kirillich it's not it's a bit of a
kulick way to ride it i guess i'm from
Cuba I think I've played him before
Nikolai no Ritson it's probably not not
born in Cuba okay so I tell Carl with d3
i'm not quite sure what I'm playing here
okay
yeah this is one one way to to play that
transposing into an isolated Queen
composition it's some playable line for
white nothing spectacular but but solid
yeah he's transposed he served
transformed the position of it taking on
c6 and so on it's still an isolated pawn
position should I go yeah I don't like
to have Bishop g5 played against me
pinning so maybe p.m. yeah makes make
sure that he doesn't play III before and
stuff and to maybe prepare be sure
basics
yeah this position is some somewhere
between equal and slightly better for
wide so nothing nothing special for
white this much is clear but certainly
play ball play ball on line okay just
simply covering stuff and we will be
eight I was thinking about Bishop a six
or so but I'm not sure that I want to
keep this uncovered mmm yeah I'm not
sure this move is going right at five
but 95 isn't isn't dangerous at all I
can just take it if I if I want or
Bishop b5 so no matter what it's not a
not a move that I need to fear
a for wants to fix the queenside but
yeah no I think it's really about equal
I thought maybe at first that he had
something but this is I've got enough
activity here against his be born and he
doesn't have any special threats him
yeah h3 is not very inspired move button
it says it's difficult to make any
progress for both sides here I'm not
sure as well but what I should do maybe
now all night f5 yeah yeah now Bishop b5
which would be my preferred answer it's
not not on but yeah what what what we
would FB should be five but we should be
five better be five yep I don't want to
get the light squared Bishop Soph
yeah this was an important trick where
are you going now Twitter serve almost
trapped in 97 I have king of aid
check
so he's giving giving up the queen but
them in fact this is this is
unbelievable I mean you just blunt let
the Queen and it's still working you can
still play this position because of
Bishop before with the check yeah
sometimes luck plays a role in chess
okay let's go here what is this material
voice its eyes got peace and rook and
the piece from the Queen so it's so
something you can play
check-check
should I go there probably let's nope we
should check out something anyway I rook
takes time not sure I guess Queen takes
us better
Queen d7 is the threat
you're more strapping it maybe you can
take a playbook c5
and taking here may be queen of five
need to get active activate McQueen
especially this is the piece that is not
not having the Queen
after maybe maybe even 91 and then it is
again the night the night before
ok can I can do here 94 q1 check this is
a useful check useful tactic check yeah
and the white resigned wow yeah it was
it was a bit weird but that that this
was still still playable he completed he
overlooked Bishop before this this move
and 97 it was just just a coincidence
that it was working at least he candy
can continue to play for a bit computer
actually wants to go King h8 yeah maybe
this is easier I was only now realizing
that this was a Channing but that it
probably working for like I mean winning
also but strange strange things yeah
here he probably needs to do something
else I mean or at least here play Queen
Queen d4 was was maybe in move with
Queen this thing was a possibility
Garrity he overlooked Bishop before
simply alright thanks for watching